hello problem is you do sound a lot like
the other guy because both of you seem
to both of you seem to not entertain the
possibility that you might not get a
majority which is absolutely ridiculous
and you really need to be honest with
voters about what you might do in the
event that you don't what was your name
I'm sorry Rebecca Rebecca let me let me
try and do better than the other guy on
on this one you know he was saying at
the end David Cameron that if you didn't
get a majority it meant this business of
going into a darkened room with Nick
Clegg now I don't like that sound of
that at all front prep for a whole range
of reasons but but but but I don't like
it for for one for one particular reason
I'm not gonna start bartering away my
manifester whatever the outcome of the
election right even if I don't win a
majority I've got a manifesto you know
some of you may have read it not that
many people but some of some people may
have read it but the manifestos out
there if I am the Prime Minister I'm
going to do everything I can to get my
manifesto not start trading for Nick
Clegg or anyone else's manifesto and so
you know I think we're in a sort of new
world in Britain it was the first
coalition obviously this coalition that
had been for a long time but in my view
we don't have a majority government it
is not about saying go into a darkened
room with somebody and then start
lopping off bits of your manifesto that
isn't what you're voting for that isn't
what Labour voters are voting for it's
not going to happen if I'm Prime
Minister we go